you can't give away what you don't have
now it sounds ridiculous but it's more
than what meets the ear as you hear this
you can't give away what you don't have
people who are not good at giving away
love can't give away love because they
don't have it to give away if I want to
give you a dozen oranges I can't give
you those dozen oranges unless I go out
and pick up 12 oranges someplace
otherwise all it is is just empty
rhetoric and the same thing is true of
virtually everything in your life you
can't give away love for others if you
don't have love in here to give away if
what you have in here is contempt if
what you have in here is anger if you
haven't here is fear then these are the
things you're going to be giving away in
your life the second thing that the ego
teaches us is that Who I am is not only
what I have but Who I am is what I do
what I accomplish and so we spend a big
hunk of our lives believing that the way
that we become quote successful happy
fulfilled self actualized whatever it
might be is on the basis of what I
accomplished what my resume looks like
how many promotions I get and so we send
our children off to school and we ask
them to learn to identify themselves on
how much they get and what they
accomplished your grades become more
important than what it is that you are
studying what you own what clothes you
wear what labels you have and so on and
we become obsessed with this kind of
absurdity and we this is the false self
at work you just watch - amazing clips
from Wayne Dyer take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]